congressman john lewis's legacy has
inspired a new generation of civil
rights activists including those in the
black lives matter movement
jerika duncan spoke with two co-founders
of the movement patrice cullers
and opal time she also talked with dr
bernice king the daughter of dr martin
luther king jr
they discussed congressman lewis's fight
for equality and how it can be carried
on
what did you all learn from him and how
are you using his message
to continue your efforts in black lives
matter
you know i think i learned that this is
a long-haul fight and struggle that the
work that we do
matters most if we stay inside of it and
if we recognize that nothing changes
overnight
my father defined a revolt as moving
people
but a revolution as changing people and
systems so the question is whether
we will see the true change in
manifestation
that this movement now becomes
revolutionary who do you see as that
next group of people to leave this
movement we do need to ensure that there
are people
uh that are spokespersons even if it's
20
and that the messaging is the same you
don't have to literally
say the exact same words but the the
narrative and the focus
and the target that those people who
represent
this generation are sending that same
message
so much of what we get to do in our day
is
because of the tremendous work that our
ancestors and freedom fighters
before us did and we stand on the
shoulders
of so many giants who came before us i
saw
his ability and capacity to behold
the weight of the struggle but also
there was a levity
to how he showed up and i think that's
incredibly powerful
for me um as a as an organizer who's
been in this struggle
and also for other younger organizers
younger than us
who are newly joining this fight what do
you think
congressman lewis is saying right now
continue to get in good trouble
continue to get in the way continue to
fight for justice and
freedom and equity and do it in a
non-violent way that
love is the foundation
we also talked about this moment right
here which we just heard speaker pelosi
mentioned and
what it meant to those co-founders of
black lives matter it's that image
of congressman lewis standing strong
there on black lives matter plaza you
know the co-founder
one of the co-founders of black lives
matter patrice cullers put it to me like
this she said what comes to mind when
she saw that photo
is that we are our ancestors wildest
dreams and she even said that what made
it special is that
congressman lewis was that ancestor but
he got to see his dream
to fruition before his death yeah that
was a very powerful moment eureka duncan
thank you